[Music]
foreign
doing something that sort of makes other
people go wow you just did that just
that mental attitude just just keep
going until you can't know more really
pretty much everything that's what the
sport cycling is based around especially
the type of cycling we do which is all
long distance you're always pushing
yourself always trying to
go further harder for longer
nutrition is massively key in any
endurance Sport and if you've got a car
you don't put Petra in it
it's not going to go well unless it's
electric car nowadays but you know what
I'm trying to say as long as you keep
that tank at a good level you're able to
maintain an effort for a very very long
period of time certainly much longer
than you probably would have imagined
you could I'd say nutrition is key you
know in
endurance sport once you've done it
properly and you've actually feel well
the difference is massive it's been able
to help me develop and push through and
progress as a as an athlete through
these races you might be good for half a
stage or quarter stage if you're not
well fueled if you're not well prepared
you might as well not be on the
Starlight